New York Times bestselling author her
name is Leon Moriarty she has sold more
than 14 million books worldwide and
Hollywood has Sur taken notice Nicole
Kidman is set to star and executive
produced the adaptation a Moriarty's new
page-turner it's called nine perfect
strangers this book follows people
trying to transform their lives at a
wellness retreat run by a very how shall
we say it's centric leader trust me you
don't want to go lay early on or ERT
joins us at the table to discuss it's so
good to meet you yes really big fan of
your work but let's talk about this why
you decided to set it at a wellness
retreat because something stood out to
me you said men always talk about
dropping weight women talk about losing
weight and that's so true why did you
decide don't you think that's true okay
I've never heard a guy John say you know
I need to lose some weight they say I
need to drop some weight what's a
distinction there and why did you choose
to have it at a retreat well I think the
distinction is just that women obviously
have such an emotional connection to
their bodies and such a sense of shame
whereas men just yeah they drop they can
and also they do just drop the weight so
that's part of it and the reason I chose
to set it at a wellness retreat it
actually all started with a joke
so after big little lies came out I kept
making the same joke and the joke was
I'm going to set my next book at a
tropical island resort and I'm going to
have to do a lot of research
meticulously yeah but then I started
thinking actually why not a tropical
island resort could make a perfect
setting for a book but then I record a
health resort that I went to with a
girlfriend where we smuggled in some
contraband
what's contraband things well so
alcohols things like champagne and
chocolates and coffee taken away from
you well no they did they did see it in
the back of the car and but then they
drove the car off so then we had to
punch through the resort until we
tracked down the car yeah so we got it
in the air well you do need something to
get you through all of that well yes
why though but there's something about
what people are seeking when they are
going to seek wellness adjust relaxation
it's um its transformation really I
think it's that desire to be somebody
else so when I was doing research for
this book I did just a little five-day
retreat and I remember on the drive
there honestly thinking to myself maybe
I'll be transformed by the end of this
five days but of course I stopped at the
first cafe the way back home and which
character do you see Nicole Kidman
playing definitely the Masha so the 6
foot tall charismatic narcissistic
Russian resort leader good casting and
we can't help but notice your Australian
accent and you are the first Australian
author to debut number one in this
country go you thank you thank you for a
big little lies a big little lies which
before there was any announcement about
the TV just like to say that I did that
on my own and it's part two when you got
Meryl Streep Liana I got yes so my
sister said to me I only write her if
you think it would be fun to Ryder and
why not write a role for your favorite
actress so I thought why not write a
role for Meryl stream and then I was
looking up to see what her middle name
was because I thought it might be fun to
call the character by her middle name
and I found out that her real name is
Mary Louise thank you so much and 9
perfect strangers is on sale now